Speaker 1: Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
has been fired by Fox News. What was initially
reported as they have parted ways is very
clearly a firing as far as we know. As of
Tucker's last show on Friday, he expected
to be back on the air last night. We have
four different potential reasons that may
have played a role in what took place,
and I will tell you about all of them. But do not
be confused. This is a firing. We have a report
from The Washington Post. Tucker Carlson is out at
Fox News after Dominion lawsuit disclosures. This
is potentially one element of the firing, which
is that the discovery from the Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News, which led to a settlement of
$787.5 million in favor of Dominion included the
release of text messages from Tucker Carlson,
some of which contain Tucker saying he hates
Trump passionately, which is interesting, but
also text messages in which Tucker Carlson was
criticizing Fox management. That's not a great
thing if you are Fox News and now you've got
to deal with this guy. We also have this lawsuit
that is forthcoming related to harassment taking
place within the walls of the Tucker Carlson
production apparatus. I guess we would call it.
A woman has filed the lawsuit and makes all sorts
of very, very tough allegations. And that is a
mess for Fox News as well. In addition to this,
we have potentially a forthcoming lawsuit from
Ray Epps. Ray Epps is this guy who was
in Washington, DC on January 5th, 2021,
and many people, including Tucker Carlson, have
made Ray Epps his life a living hell, signal
boosting conspiracy theories that Ray Epps is
some kind of agent provocateur or FBI informant or
whatever the case may be, who was trying to entrap
rioters by encouraging them to go and riot when
they had no plan to do so. There's no evidence
of any of that. And there was a 60 Minutes piece
on Sunday, just two days ago, in which Ray Epps
specifically points to Tucker Carlson and saying,
essentially, he's made my life a living hell.
That is also a lawsuit concerned. So when you
step back and you think about it, Tucker Carlson,
responsible to some degree for giving voice to
those conspiracies that led to the $787 million
settlement for Dominion. In addition to that, that
very lawsuit releasing text messages from Tucker
Carlson that make it a little awkward to have him
working for you. You've got one lawsuit already
with another lawsuit potentially forthcoming,
as good as his ratings were, this guy is really
a headache for you. And we have video. This was
the end of Tucker, what ended up being Tucker
Carlson's final episode on Friday. He says, I'll
be back Monday. And there is every indication that
he believed he would be back on the air yesterday.
Speaker 2: We just thought, what a great way
to end the week. Yeah, truly. That was a great
segment and. I was grateful that you came on.
And I'm especially grateful for the pie. Thank
you for having me. Appreciate it. Employee of
the Week. We're going to Where does make it of
the year? Tell the morale of Coco's Pizza. That's
it for us for the week. We'll be back. By the way,
the entire episode of Let Them Eat Bugs. Not quite
as good as pizza. Streaming now on Fox Station
is a promo code originals for 30 days free.
And we'll be back on Monday. In the meantime,
have the best weekend with the ones that you love.
Speaker 1: There it is. We'll be back on Monday.
So every indication that he would be back.
So listen, let's think through the larger
implications here. Will Tucker ultimately be
replaced with someone worse? It's impossible.
Last night, Brian KILMEADE from Fox and Friends
filled in for Tucker and we'll have a few seconds
of that. It was pretty awkward a little bit
later in the show. Imagine the bigger picture,
though. Tucker Carlson was reportedly fired
by Fox, at least in part for the things he
said about Fox management as revealed in the
Dominion lawsuit. So in some incredible way,
Trump's harebrained election lies, which led to
the attacks on Dominion, which led to the lawsuit,
led to Tucker's firing. In a sense, Tucker's
firing came from the big lie about the 2020
election in terms of whether it's good for the
country to have Tucker off the air, what will
likely be temporarily, because Tucker is going to
find something else, of course. Tucker broke the
brains of millions of people. He was seen by
many on the right as a real thinker, which is
hilarious. And so in some sense, the country is
better off with Tucker not spouting propaganda.
On the other hand, he'll find some other place
to do it. It just won't be Fox. Additionally,
Don Lemon was fired from CNN yesterday. That
relates to what happened with Tucker in some
ways. Will delve into that in more detail on the
bonus show later today. So let's take a quick
break. Make sure you're subscribed on the YouTube
channel. If you're just listening today, you can
watch. I know it's crazy to think there's a video
component to this insane show that we do every
day. But there is. You can watch at YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show. We're going to take
a quick break. Let emotions simmer on set and
then we'll be back with much more in a moment